I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everyone and welcome to Conflict Resolution. I'm talking to you from my closet today. I know we're both in our closets today. What is happening? We are both talking to each other from our closets. And Sam and Cody are watching. I'm looking at Cody's cat. Love it. Sam's dog is somewhere there. This is where we're at now, folks.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来这个终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好，欢迎来到“冲突解决”。今天我在衣橱里跟你们说话。我知道我们今天都在衣橱里。发生什么事了？我们都在各自的衣橱里跟对方说话。山姆和科迪在看着。我在看科迪的猫。太棒了。山姆的狗就在某个地方。各位，这就是我们现在的状况。
Angela, your shirts are very well folded. Are those Josh's shirts? No, baby girl. Baby girl. Are we doing that again this week? We are. Here's the thing. I started every morning by talking to my family in Texas and Louisiana. And then it just is kind of with me for the whole day. This is my closet. My own closet. I share it with no one. It is a personal life victory. Oh my gosh. I only get one side of a closet. We have one closet and I get one side and we get the other. Although, to be honest, I think I have encroached on about a third of his side. Well, Josh has his own closet, but one wall of it is my shoes.
安吉拉，你的衬衫叠得真好。那是乔什的衬衫吗？不，乖乖。乖乖。我们这周又要来这一套吗？是的。事情是这样的，我每天早晨都是从跟我在德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州的家人通话开始的。然后这种状态就会一直伴随着我一整天。这是我的衣橱。我自己的衣橱。我跟任何人都不分享。这是一场个人生活的伟大胜利。哦天哪。我只能分到衣橱的一侧。我们只有一个衣橱，他用一侧，我们用另一侧。不过说实话，我觉得我的衣服大概侵占了他那一侧的三分之一吧。好吧，乔什有他自己的衣橱，但它的一面墙挂满了我的鞋子。
This is the riveting content that people tuned in for. I know. I know. Listen, but just bear with me one second. Here is a perk of not growing since like your junior year of high school. Maybe a little wider in some places, but I've had the same shoe size. Angela, you're describing most adults. I mean, most adults hit their peak height somewhere around their junior, senior year of high school. It's not like other people are continuing to grow four or five inches in their 20s and 30s. Do you have the same size foot as like when you were sophomore?
这就是人们收听的引人入胜的内容。我知道。我知道。听着，但请大家包容我一秒钟。自从高中初中以来就没长高过，这就是一个好处。也许某些地方稍微宽了一点，但我的鞋码一直没变。安吉拉，你这形容的是大多数成年人啊。我的意思是，大多数成年人在高中高一高二左右就达到了身高的巅峰。又不是说别人到了二十多三十多岁还在长高四五英寸。你现在的脚码跟上高二时一样吗？
Yes, of course. You do? Yeah. I've been a seven and a half medium since like, you know, junior year of high school. I was fully grown when I went to college. I was fully grown. It's true. Oh, I unzipped my hoodie. Could y'all hear that? It sounded like a toot. It sounded like you tooted. What? It wasn't a toot. It sounded like a toot. It's good that you're claiming that you unzipped your hoodie. It is. Oh, my gosh. I see how it is. So we're here. It's Conflict Resolution Day, if you
对，当然一样。你一样吗？对啊。从高中初中开始，我就是七号半中码了。我上大学时就已经完全长成了。我完全长成了。真的。哦，我拉开了连帽衫的拉链。你们听见了吗？听起来像放了个屁。听起来就像你放了个屁。什么？那才不是放屁。听起来就像放了个屁。你非要辩解说那是你在拉连帽衫拉链，这倒也挺好。确实。哦，天哪。我算是看明白了。所以我们在这。今天是冲突解决日，如果你
can't tell. It's season two, episode 21, written by Greg Daniels and directed by Charles McDougal. Action! This was a really, really fun one for me. And I love Charles and he and I got to play a lot in this episode because guess what? Angela Martin has a lot of conflicts. Should I give a summary? Yes. All right. So there are two main things that happen in this episode. One, everyone at Dunder
看不出来的话。这是第二季第二十一集，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。开拍！对我来说，这一集真的非常非常有趣。我非常喜欢查尔斯，在这集里我和他有很多发挥的空间，因为你猜怎么着？安吉拉·马丁有很多冲突。我要做个总结吗？好啊。那么，这一集里主要发生了两件事。第一，邓德
Mifflin is being issued an ID badge. So one by one, people go into the break room and have their photo taken for their badge. And then secondly, Michael takes the stack of employee complaints from Toby and starts trying to resolve them one by one by forcing people to confront one another at work. Yeah. So I have one little thing about this episode. So Dwight is like going on and on about how horrible the security is at the office, right, at Dunder Mifflin. We get these badges. We never wear them again. No. Well, you know, there's this deleted scene where it's supposedly the next day and we're
米夫林的每个人都要领一张身份胸牌。所以大家排队走进休息室，拍照制作胸牌。第二，迈克尔拿起了托比收集的一叠员工投诉，开始通过强迫大家在工作中当面对质，试图逐一解决这些问题。对。所以关于这一集我有一件小事要说。迪怀特一直在喋喋不休地抱怨办公室的安保有多糟糕，对吧，就是在邓德米夫林。我们拿到了这些胸牌。结果再也没戴过。没有。好吧，你知道的，有一个被删减的片段，据说是第二天，我们
all walking in in the morning and we all have our badges on and Hank is in the scene and Hank keeps insisting that Dwight show his ID badge and he pretends like he can't read it and then Dwight misses the elevator. So I guess we wore them once for a tag that never aired. Right. But no, we don't ever. It's, you know, it's sort of the casual Friday of it all. Right. It really is. Yeah. It really is. It really. Look, Jen, I brought it back to casual Friday for you. I appreciate that. I really appreciate that. Are you going to hit me with some fast facts?
大家早上走进来时都戴着胸牌，汉克也在那个镜头里，汉克一直坚持要求迪怀特出示他的胸牌，他假装自己看不清，然后迪怀特就错过了电梯。所以我想我们为了一个从未播出的尾声片段戴过一次吧。对。但是没有，我们从来没戴过。你知道的，这其实就是周五便服日那档子事。对。确实是。是的。真的。你看，简，我为了你把它扯回周五便服日了。我很感激。我真的很感激。你要用一些快讯来砸我吗？
You know I am. I'm going to hit you with some fast facts. Can I get my sting? Fast facts. Yeah. That's from BDB, by the way. I did not give him a shout out last week. So I wanted to do that this week. He's a sound engineer who sent us that sting. Thank you so much for that sting. It does make me feel like I'm like in a 1980s game show or something. Fast facts. I love it. All right. Fast fact number one. We have a special guest star in this episode playing the ID badge photographer. It is Scott Atzit.
你知道我会的。我要用快讯来砸你。能给我来段音效吗？快讯。对。顺便说一句，那是BDB的创意。上周我没有感谢他。所以我这周想补上。他是给我们发送这段音效的音频工程师。非常感谢你提供的音效。这确实让我觉得自己好像在参加上世纪80年代的游戏节目什么的。快讯。我太喜欢了。好的，快讯一号。我们在这一集中有一位特别客串演员，饰演胸牌摄影师。他就是斯科特·阿茨特。
Scott Atzit. I love this fella so much. I've known him a really long time. He's an improv butt of mine back from the Improv Olympic days and I was texting with him last night. I told him we were watching this episode and he had some fun things to say. Do you want to hear him? No, I do. Scott Atzit is an amazing improviser, performer, comedian. You might know him from 30 Rock. Also your children know him as Baymax. He's Baymax and Big Hero 6. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da. Anyway, okay. That's my Baymax, Scott. You do it much better.
斯科特·阿茨特。我太喜欢这家伙了。我认识他很久了。他是我当年即兴奥林匹克时期的即兴喜剧搭档，我昨晚还给他发短信了。我告诉他我们正在看这一集，他讲了一些有趣的事情。你想听听吗？不，我想听。斯科特·阿茨特是一位了不起的即兴演员、表演者、喜剧演员。你可能在《我为喜剧狂》里认识他。你的孩子们也认识他，他就是大白。《超能陆战队》里的那只大白。巴达达达达达达。总之，好吧。那是我的大白，斯科特。你模仿得好多了。
So here's a little behind the scenes tidbit that he shared with me that he remembers from filming this episode. He said he remembers that Ricky Gervais came to visit set this week and everyone was a buzz. He said that Ricky seemed delighted and surprised by the scale of the production of our set and everything compared to maybe what his production of it had been like in the UK and he said that Ricky was just very humble and sweet. Oh my gosh. I did not remember that Ricky visited during this episode. Yeah. I mean, he popped by in and out those first couple seasons, you know, but Scott remembered meeting him and he just said that he was just really nice.
这里有一个他分享给我的幕后小花絮，是他拍摄这一集时的记忆。他说他记得瑞克·热维斯这周来片场参观了，每个人都兴奋不已。他说，与英国的制作规模相比，瑞克对我们片场以及各方面的制作规模似乎感到既惊喜又高兴，而且他说瑞克非常谦虚可爱。哦天哪。我不记得瑞克在这集拍摄期间来参观过。对。我的前几季里他确实时不时会来串门，你知道的，但斯科特记得见过他，而且他说他真的非常随和。
Oh my gosh. That's like a fast fact within a fast fact. What? A double fast fact? Did I help you get a double fast fact? You did. You did. Angela, I have a fun fact within this fast fact. Both you and Scott have appeared in two episodes of the TV show Monk. I was in one episode, yes, and I played the murderer. Well, Scott was on seasons three and four. So between the two of you, you cover four
哦天哪。这就像是快讯里的快讯。什么？双重快讯？我帮你弄到一个双重快讯了吗？对，你弄到了。安吉拉，我这个快讯里还有一个有趣的事实。你和斯科特都出演过电视剧《神探阿蒙》的两个不同剧集。我出演过一集，是的，我演的是凶手。好吧，斯科特出演了第三季和第四季。所以你们俩加起来，涵盖了《神探阿蒙》的四季
seasons of Monk. Congratulations. Yes. That's my fun fact. Monk was so much fun to shoot and Tony Shaloub was the nicest. We sat on like a little bench in between scenes and he was throwing something to try to get it in the trash can. And when it hit the trash can, it made like a ping-a-ling and I started laughing and he started laughing and I said, I mean, that was kind of a funny noise. And then the two of us sat there and did our impressions of the noises of things going in the trash can like ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling,
。恭喜。是的。这就是我的趣事。《神探阿蒙》拍摄起来太有趣了，托尼·夏鲁赫人超级好。我们在两场戏的间隙坐在一张小长凳上，他一直在扔某种东西，试图把它扔进垃圾桶里。当它击中垃圾桶时，发出了类似“叮铃”的一声，我笑了起来，他也笑了，我说，我的意思是，那声音听起来有点搞笑。然后我们俩就坐在那里，模仿各种东西掉进垃圾桶的声音，比如叮铃、叮铃、
ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling, ping-a-ling. We were such dorks and we cracked up. I don't know. He's just so fun. I just adored him. That fast fact was just chock full of fun and fast facts. That was a very full fast fact. It was a full fast fact. It was a full, fun, double fast fact. Fantastically fun full fast fact. Oh my gosh. Fast fact number two. Okay. Fast fact number two is a fan question from Zach Akers. And here's what he wrote in to say. Why does Jim do his talking heads in front
叮铃、叮铃、叮铃、叮铃、叮铃、叮铃、叮铃、叮铃。我们真是两个书呆子，笑得前仰后合。不知道为什么。他就是这么有趣。我太喜欢他了。那个快讯简直塞满了有趣的事实和快讯。那是一个非常饱满的快讯。那是一个充实的快讯。那是一个充实、有趣的双重快讯。极其有趣的饱满快讯。哦天哪。快讯二号。好的。快讯二号是来自扎克·阿克斯的粉丝提问。他是这样写的。为什么吉姆的面对镜头独白总是面向
of the outside facing window while everyone else's talking heads are inside of the window that faces the bullpen of the office? He says, in Boo's Cruise and some later episodes, there are Jim Pam talking heads in front of the outside window, but neither Pam nor anyone else normally sits in front of that outside window. And then he noticed because Jim has several talking heads in this one. He was like, it's really prominent in this episode that Jim is there. So I thought that was a great question and such a wise observation I had to investigate. Now that is a great catch. It really is.
朝外的窗户，而其他所有人的面对镜头独白都是面向办公室公共办公区的那扇窗户？他说，在《寻找伴侣》和一些后面的剧集里，有一些吉姆和帕姆的面对镜头独白是在朝外窗户前拍摄的，但平时不管是帕姆还是其他任何人都不会坐在那个朝外窗户前面。然后他注意到了这一点，因为吉姆这一集里有好几个独白。他觉得：吉姆坐在那儿在这一集里真的太显眼了。所以我觉得这是一个很好的问题，而且观察力非常敏锐，我必须去调查一下。这真是一个绝妙的发现。确实如此。
So I emailed Greg Daniels and I asked him, was this deliberate? Was this an accident? What does he have to say? And he said that it was something that Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer suggested to Greg starting with the pilot and Greg absolutely loved it. He said Randall's intention here was that it didn't necessarily have to be only Jim, but the idea was that any character that had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin or held some sort of internal optimism would sit in front of a window leading out into the world. But characters who didn't want to leave Dunder Mifflin or who maybe were in more of a position of being trapped would do their talking heads facing into the office.
所以我给格雷格·丹尼尔斯发了电子邮件，问他，这是刻意的吗？这是一个失误吗？他有什么要说的？他说，这是我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩从试播集开始就向格雷格建议的，格雷格非常喜欢这个想法。他说兰德尔的意图并不是说这一定只能是吉姆，而是任何在邓德米夫林之外有未来或者抱有某种内部乐观主义的角色，都会坐在通往外面世界的窗户前。但那些不想离开邓德米夫林或者可能觉得被困住的角色，则会面向办公室内部进行面对镜头独白。
Wow. That's so deep. That's really deep. Yeah. I'm sitting here racking my brain to think of my character ever sat on that other wall with the window facing out behind her and the one that comes to my mind and I think it might be the only one. I'm trying to think if there's any other one. It was when you and I did Big Preggs, Little Preggs.
哇。这太深刻了。真的很深刻。是的。我坐在这里绞尽脑汁地想，我的角色是否也曾坐在另一面墙前，背后是朝外的窗户，浮现在我脑海里的一个场景，而且我觉得可能也是唯一的一个。我在想有没有别的场景。那就是你和我录制“大孕妇，小孕妇”的时候。
Yeah. We did. I think it's the only time I ever sat there. Well, for a very long time, I only sat there if I was with Jim, which was really the only possible future for Pam outside of the office. Wow. That's so deep. I think, you know, isn't that crazy? But otherwise, she was rather trapped in her, you know, bad
对。我们录过。我想这是我唯一一次坐在那里。好吧，在很长一段时间里，我只有在跟吉姆坐在一起时才会坐在那里，对帕姆来说，这其实也是她在办公室之外唯一的未来可能。哇。太深刻了。你不觉得，（这不是很疯狂吗？）但除此之外，她其实是被困在了她那（你知道的）和罗伊在一起的糟糕决定中。
decision of being with Roy. Trapped or content, you know? I mean, some of us were just happy with our lot in life. Yes. Well, that is fascinating and I like it. Yeah. I thought that was a good one. So thank you so much, Zach, for pointing that out and writing in. Now, finally, Fast Facts number three, Angela, it's a Fast Facts flashback. What are you doing?
被困住或者感到满足，你知道的？我的意思是，我们当中有些人对自己的生活现状已经很满意了。是的。好吧，这太迷人了，我很喜欢。对。我觉得这是一个很好的问题。所以非常感谢扎克指出来并写信给我们。现在，最后是快讯三号，安吉拉，这是一个快讯闪回。你在干什么？
Why are you drunk? So, here is this Fast Facts. This episode was filmed during May 2006. And so, Angela, my question for both of us is, what were you doing? Flashback now to May 2006 and what were you up to? Well, I had a journal entry from May 3rd, 2006. This is what I wrote. I wrote that I was doing a photo shoot with my cat, Lucy, for Cat Fancy Magazine. Angela Kinsey. What?
你为什么喝醉了？所以，这就是这个快讯。这一集是在2006年5月拍摄的。所以，安吉拉，我对我们两个人的问题是，你们当时在干什么？现在闪回到2006年5月，你在忙些什么？好吧，我有一篇2006年5月3日的日记。我是这么写的。我写道我正在和我的猫露西一起为《Cat Fancy》杂志拍摄一组照片。安吉拉·金西。什么？
Shut the front door right now. What? Do you know what I wrote in my journal? This is the week of May. What? In 2006, I did a photo shoot with my cat, Andy, for People Magazine. I'm not joking. I'm not joking, lady.
马给我把前门关上。什么？你知道我在日记里写了什么吗？这是五月份的某一周。什么？在2006年，我和我的猫安迪一起为《人物》杂志拍摄了一组照片。我没开玩笑。我真没开玩笑，女士。
Lady, how did we not know that we did photo shoots with our cats at this cute time? What is going on in the world? I feel like we probably at the time knew, but it's hilarious to me for us to both share our journal entries from early May, 2006, and we were both so tickled that we were taking photos with our cats. Oh, my gosh. First of all, this is why we're BFFs, all right? This is why. Our life has very strange ways that it is parallel.
天哪，我们怎么会不知道在这么可爱的时期和我们的猫一起拍了照片呢？这个世界到底是怎么了？我觉得当时我们可能知道，但把我们在2006年5月初的日记拿出来分享，我还是觉得太搞笑了，我们俩当时都因为和猫咪拍照而感到那么高兴。哦，天哪。首先，这就是为什么我们是闺蜜，好吗？这就是原因。我们的生活有一种非常奇怪的平行方式。
So was Lucy on the cover of Cat Fancy? No, Lucy was not on the cover because she was a rescue. She was not a purebred cat. But also, Jenna, Cat Fancy doesn't let humans on the cover. So that's like it's only cats on the cover. Okay. But the cool thing was that Lucy and I got like, I think, I mean, I saved the magazine. I think we got like four pages. So Lucy and I are in the center, I guess, for the center fold.
露西上了《Cat Fancy》杂志的封面吗？没有，露西没有上封面，因为她是一只救助猫。她不是纯种猫。但是，珍娜，《Cat Fancy》不让平民上封面。所以封面只有猫。好吧。但酷的是，露西和我得到了，我想，我的意思是，我留下了那本杂志。我想我们大约有四页的篇幅。所以露西和我都在中心，我想是在中缝页。
Oh, you are the center fold of Cat Fancy magazine. So Lucy and I look amazing. There's some of the best pictures I feel like I have. How was she during the photo shoot? Well, yeah, I should probably give you some backstory about Lucy. Lucy loved to sleep. So Lucy just laid there. And I mean, Lucy, I love her. R.I.P. Lucy, she had a great long life, but she really just loved to lounge. She was a lounger. So I, in many shots, I'm just laying next to her because that's like her favorite thing to do. But what about you? What was your people magazine shoot like with Andy?
哦，你是《Cat Fancy》杂志的中缝女郎。所以露西和我都看起来棒极了。我觉得这些是我拍过的最好的一些照片。她在拍照时表现怎么样？好吧，是的，我可能应该告诉你一些关于露西的背景故事。露西喜欢睡觉。所以露西就躺在那里。我是说，露西，我爱她。R.I.P. 露西，她过着很长很美好的生活，但她其实就是喜欢闲逛。她是个喜欢闲逛的人。所以我在很多镜头里都只是躺在她旁边，因为那是她最喜欢做的事情。但你呢？你和安迪的《人物》杂志拍摄是什么样的？
Okay. Well, Andy was also a rescue, but he was a semifaral cat. I had found him. He was eating out of a dumpster back in Kirksville, Missouri, where I went to college. I think he was about like five or six months old when I got him. And he was just always a little, we said he was always a little wild. And he loved me and he snuggled me and he was so gentle and sweet, but he didn't love strangers in the house. And so when the people magazine guys came over, not only were they all there kind of causing a ruckus, you know, and Andy was a little bit like, I'm out of here. They wanted to do the photo shoot outside and they wanted me to hold him forget it. Mine was inside. Oh, oh my gosh. I'm in like full hair
好吧。安迪也是一只救助猫，但他是一只半野猫。我发现他的。他在密苏里州柯克斯维尔我上大学时的垃圾桶里找东西吃。我得到他时，他大概五六个月大。他总是有点，我们说他总是有点野性。他爱我，也喜欢依偎我，他是那么温柔可爱，但他不喜欢家里有陌生人。所以当《人物》杂志的人来的时候，不仅他们都在那里制造骚动，你知道的，安迪有点像是：我可要走了。他们想在外面进行拍摄，还想让我抱着他，想得美！我的拍摄是在里面。哦，天哪。我梳着完美的头发
and makeup with this dress on. They were like, okay, we're ready for you. Will you come out with Andy? So I'm holding Andy. And I think if you look in the photo, you can see that he and I are both a little tense, but I'm smiling super big as if I'm not tense. And I wrote in my journal, Angela, I wrote in my journal that he clawed my stomach and I had like, like bloody claw marks in my stomach from the photo shoot because he wanted to get away. Oh, lady, I can't believe that we both did cat photo shoots in May of 2006. And also that we both wrote about it in our journals and also that our experiences were so vastly different. I do remember like calling my mom and I was so excited because I hadn't
化着妆，穿着这条裙子。他们说，好了，我们准备好了。你愿意带着安迪出来吗？所以我抱着安迪。我想如果你看照片，你会发现他和我都稍微有点紧张，但我笑得超级灿烂，好像我一点也不紧张。我在日记里写道，安吉拉，我在日记里写道，他抓伤了我的肚子，我的肚子上有像血淋淋的抓痕，因为拍照时他想逃跑。哦，天哪，我简直不敢相信我们俩都在2006年5月拍了猫咪写真！而且我们都在日记里写了这件事，而且我们的经历是如此截然不同。我还记得给我妈妈打电话，我当时太兴奋了，因为我从来没有
really been in any magazines ever, obviously in my whole life. And I was like, mom, I'm going to be in cat fancy. And my mom was like, what? I was like, me and Lucy, mom. Anyway, that is so cute. I love that. Now I really want to see, I remember you doing that, but now I need to see the picture. Okay, well, I have a ton of makeup on, just a ton of makeup and I'm smiling in a really weird maniacal way. And I called my mom after that photo shoot Angela and my mom was so sweet. She was like, oh, I am just so proud of you both. Just so proud of you both. She's like, just think about that little kitten that you found in that dumpster in Kirk'sville, Missouri. He drove all the way to Los Angeles with you
上过任何杂志，显然后来的人生也没有。我说：妈妈，我要上《Cat Fancy》了。我妈说：什么？我说：我和露西，妈妈。总之，太可爱了。我很喜欢。现在我真的很想看看，我记得你做过那件事，但我现在需要看照片。好吧，我化了厚厚的一层妆，就是厚厚的一层妆，我用一种非常诡异的狂热方式微笑着。安吉拉，拍照后我给我妈打电话，我妈人太好了。她说：哦，我为你们俩感到骄傲。真的为你们俩骄傲。她说：想想你在密苏里州柯克斯维尔的那个垃圾桶里发现的那只小猫。他一路开车陪你到洛杉矶
onto the pages of People Magazine. What a life you've given him. That is, that is so adorable. That is such a mom moment. Oh my Lord. I know. Well, that's it. That's the end. That was my third fast fact, fast fact flashback. I like it. Those were really fun. All right, guys, well, maybe we should take a break and then we'll come back to break down this episode of conflict resolution. Let's get into it. Angela Martin, I have a card for this episode and it's called the whole office sass. Oh, I think I know the scene you're talking about. I can't wait. And we're back. Angela, you open up this episode. I do this. I mean, I don't think this happens very often with my character, but it starts
上了《人物》杂志的版面。你给了他多么棒的一生啊。这，这真是太可爱了。这真是一个典型的妈妈时刻。哦，天哪。我懂。好吧，就是这样。结束了。那是我的第三个冷知识，冷知识闪回。我喜欢。那些真的很有趣。好了，伙计们，也许我们应该休息一下，然后回来剖析《冲突解决》这一集。让我们开始吧。安吉拉·马丁，我为这一集准备了一张卡片，它叫做“整个办公室的俏皮话”。哦，我想我知道你在说哪个场景。我等不及了。我们回来了。安吉拉，这一集由你开场。我演的。我的意思是，我觉得这在我的角色身上不常发生，但它开始了
with me very quickly at like one second in. I'm making copies on that copier and then the camera pans over to you and Kevin at reception. Angela, why didn't you close the top of the copier when you're making the copy? I'm not the only person who noticed this because Molly net also would like to know Angela. Probably because that copier didn't work. Really? There was always a catch to that copier. One time I made copies and I had to hold the side of it shut. I think that they didn't want me to shut it there. That would have been specific. That would have been Charles McDougal as a director. He really had his eye on everything. So there was definitely a reason to that either a if I shut it, it wouldn't work because
以我非常迅速的动作，大概在一秒钟的时候。我在那个复印机上复印，然后镜头摇向你和凯文在前台。安吉拉，你复印的时候为什么不把复印机盖合上？我不是唯一一个注意到这一点的人，因为莫莉·内特也想知道，安吉拉。可能因为那台复印机根本不好使。真的吗？那台复印机总是有毛病。有一次我复印的时候，不得不扶着它的一侧才没散架。我觉得他们不想让我把盖子合上。那应该是有意为之的。那是导演查尔斯·麦克道格尔的风格。他真的对每件事都盯得很紧。所以这绝对是有原因的，要么是：如果我合上它，它就无法工作，因为
the copier was 100 years old or they wanted that light that's like pans across the copier. Maybe they liked the effect, but it was a thought out thing. I'm sure of that. But it wasn't like Angela Martin's character choice. That's not her way. I only photocopy with a blinding light in my face. Exactly. So after you copy with the copier open, Pam is over at her desk and she's doing her wedding planning and Kevin asks if his band can play in the wedding. But Kevin is doing something that is such a pet peeve of mine. Anyone that walks up and starts tapping a table or thumping on something, I want to break their fingers. It makes me crazy. You don't like that. I can't take it. Who likes that? Who likes that? Some
那台复印机有一百岁了；要么是他们想要那种光扫过复印机的效果。也许他们喜欢那种视觉效果，但这绝对是经过深思熟虑的。我对此深信不疑。但这并不是安吉拉·马丁的角色选择。这不是她的风格。我复印时只喜欢让刺眼的光照在我的脸上。没错。所以，在你开着复印机复印之后，帕姆在她的办公桌旁规划她的婚礼，凯文问他的乐队是否可以在婚礼上演奏。但凯文正在做一件特别让我反感的事。任何走过来开始敲桌子或拍打什么东西的人，我都想掰断他们的手指。这让我抓狂。你不喜欢那样？我受不了。谁会喜欢那样？谁会喜欢那样？有些人
people are oblivious. You can walk by and be like, and they're like, whatever. But you do that around me and I'm like, what is your problem? You know what I don't love? Whistling. People who walk around just whistling. Yeah. Yeah. I can't. Yeah. Sorry whistlers. Sorry whistlers. All right. So we find out that Pam did not invite Angela to her wedding and this is because she doesn't want anyone there who's called her a hussy. Angela, in the background of my talking head where I'm talking about you calling me a hussy, you're eating in the kitchen. At 45 seconds, you seem like you are really eating. Were you hungry? Guys, check it out. 45 seconds. Angela is scarfing down whatever her food is in the background.
就是毫无眼力见。你可以从他们身旁走过，他们就像……随便吧。但你在我周围这样做，我就会想：你有什么毛病？你知道我讨厌什么吗？吹口哨。那些走来走去吹口哨的人。对。对。我受不了。对。对不起吹口哨的人。对不起吹口哨的人。好吧。所以我们发现帕姆没有邀请安吉拉参加她的婚礼，这是因为她不想让任何叫她荡妇的人去。安吉拉，在我的谈话镜头背景里，我正在谈论你叫我荡妇，而你正在厨房里吃东西。在45秒的时候，你看起来真的很饿。你当时很饿吗？伙计们，快看。45秒。安吉拉在背景里狼吞虎咽地吃着她的食物。
In the scene, they let me eat a bagel. I was really excited. Whenever I got to eat something like that, I was like, yeah, I'll eat that whole bagel. Give me some cream cheese butter. I'm here. That's the cold open, right? We come back. The episode opens with a Michael talking head and Phyllis getting her photo taken. And this is the scene where we find out that everyone's being photographed for their new ID badge. Yes. And in the deleted scenes, if you get the DVDs for this, this is a particularly great DVD. So disc four in the DVD set, disc four has commentary. It has deleted scenes. It has a blooper reel. It has fake PSAs we did. It has Olympic promos we did. It has the accountants, the webisode
在那个场景里，他们让我吃一个贝果。我真的很兴奋。每当我能吃到那样东西时，我都觉得：太好了，我要把整个贝果都吃掉。给我来点奶油奶酪黄油，我来了。那是冷开场，对吧？我们回来了。这一集以迈克尔的谈话镜头和菲莉丝拍照开场。这就是我们发现每个人都在为新工牌拍照的场景。是的。在删减片段里，如果你买了这一集的DVD，这是一个特别棒的DVD。所以DVD套装中的第四盘，第四盘有评论音轨。它有删减片段。它有NG镜头。它有我们拍的伪公益广告。它有我们拍的奥运会宣传片。它有会计师网剧
series, which won an Emmy. Yeah. So it's got, this is a very good disc. Jenna and I make no money off this. I'm just telling you, if you're an office fan, this is a great disc. But there was a deleted scene that I thought was really interesting. It was a Michael talking head and it kind of sets up the whole episode. Yeah. I know what you're talking about. In fact, I also just want to say before you explain this, I thought that the deleted scenes from this episode played like a mini episode. Did you find that? Because they start with this, like what you're talking about, they start with this amazing talking head for Michael. Exactly. So Michael is talking about how, well, one of the things is he hates it when
系列，还得过艾美奖。对。所以它有，这是一个非常棒的光盘。珍娜和我从这上面赚不到一分钱。我只是想告诉你，如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，这是一个绝佳的光盘。但有一个删减片段，我觉得非常有趣。那是一个迈克尔的谈话镜头，它为整集奠定了基调。是的。我知道你在说什么。事实上，在我解释之前，我也想说，我觉得这一集的删减片段就像一集迷你剧。你有这种感觉吗？因为它们以这个开始，就像你说的，它们以迈克尔的一个精彩谈话镜头开始。完全正确。所以迈克尔在谈论，嗯，其中一件事是他讨厌
people have something wrong and they won't tell you what's wrong. And he says, my dad would do that all the time. And I would look at him and I'd say, dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? Dad, what's wrong? I would do it over and over and he would just look at me like I was an idiot. That's what he says. Poor Michael. And then he also has a scene with Ryan where he is saying that it's just another kind of boring day. Nothing's going to happen. And he's talking about how on Big Brother, they tackle really important things, you know, every week. But I guess that's not real life. And he, you can tell that Michael wants to feel accomplished in this day. He wants to feel like he made
人们遇到了问题却不告诉你哪里出了问题。他说：我爸爸以前总是这样。我会看着他并说：爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？爸爸，怎么了？我会一遍又一遍地问，而他只是看着我，就像我是个白痴一样。他是这么说的。可怜的迈克尔。然后他和瑞恩也有一个场景，他说这只是又一个无聊的日子。什么都不会发生。他谈到在《老大哥》节目中，他们每周都会处理非常重要的事情，你知道的。但我想那不是现实生活。而且你，你能看出迈克尔想在这一天感到自己有所成就。他想觉得自己做出了
a difference. Well, I think that deleted scene is a great way that we motivate Michael's whole desire to take over the conflict resolution in the office for the day. Because now in the next scene, Ryan is in Michael's office and he hears Oscar yelling from the conference room. Oscar is going off. I know the beginning of that scene, the stuff that they're overhearing Oscar saying, Oscar's improvising. Because they were like, okay, just make a big fuss. They'll overhear it and it will cause them to leave Michael's office, right? Go see what the hubbub is about. Yeah. And Oscar's a very funny improviser and he got, he got to have some fun in this episode. Oh, all those lines are amazing. Michael goes into the conference
改变。嗯，我认为那个删减片段很好地激发了迈克尔想要接管办公室里的冲突调解的欲望。因为现在在下一个场景中，瑞恩在迈克尔的办公室里，他听到奥斯卡在会议室里大喊大叫。奥斯卡发飙了。我知道那个场景的开始，他们无意中听到奥斯卡说的话，奥斯卡是在即兴发挥。因为他们当时说：好吧，只要大惊小怪就行。他们会无意中听到，这会让他们离开迈克尔的办公室，对吧？去看看外面在吵什么。是的。奥斯卡是一个非常有趣的即兴演员，他在这一集里玩得很开心。哦，所有那些台词都太棒了。迈克尔走进会议
room and he sees Oscar is with Toby and he is ranting about Angela's baby jazz poster that Toby gave her in the Secret Santa Exchange at Christmas. Yes. She has hung it in accounting and Oscar doesn't want to look at it anymore. It's furious. And Toby's like, listen, you normally wouldn't hear this ranting. Normally we do it in the break room, but they're doing the security badge photos in there. So we're doing it in here instead. And this is Michael's opportunity. He has found his purpose and this is it. He's so excited. He decides he's going to resolve this conflict. So he calls Angela and Oscar into the conference room and Pam, apparently Pam had to attend. Pam gets pulled into so many things with Michael. It's
室，他看到奥斯卡和托比在一起，他正在大发雷霆，抗议托比在圣诞节秘密老人交换礼物时送给安吉拉的婴儿爵士海报。是的。她把它挂在了会计部，奥斯卡不想再看到了。他气急败坏。托比说：听着，你平时不会听到这种咆哮。通常我们在休息室做这件事，但他们在那里面拍安保工牌照片，所以我们改在这儿。这就是迈克尔的机会。他找到了自己的人生目标，就是这个。他太兴奋了。他决定去解决这个冲突。所以他把安吉拉和奥斯卡叫进会议室，还有帕姆，显然帕姆也得参加。帕姆被卷入了迈克尔的那么多事情中。这
like he needs her to document it in some way. I don't know. But I'm not writing anything down. And you hardly ever are. No. It's so true. He just likes to feel important. He likes to feel like he has a personal assistant. Yes. I like how quickly he produced this poster board that says communicate this binder. He's had this. He has been waiting. He has had this. He's ready to go. But you know what I think, Angela? I think corporate gave him this binder a long time ago to look through and study. And he's never cracked it open until now. He was like, I can't be bothered with this binder. And now suddenly he's ripped it off the shelf. We had a fan question from Aiden Magia. You know, we go through the different
就像他需要她以某种方式做记录。我不知道。但我什么也没记。而且你几乎从不记。没有。确实如此。他只是喜欢感觉自己很重要。他喜欢觉得自己有个私人助理。是的。我喜欢他迅速拿出那个写着“沟通这个文件夹”的展板。他早就准备好了。他一直在等。他一直都有这个。他随时准备开干。但你知道我觉得怎么样，安吉拉？我觉得公司很久以前给了他这个文件夹让他翻阅和学习。直到现在他才打开。他当时想：我才懒得管这破文件夹呢。现在突然把它从书架上拿了下来。我们收到了来自阿登·马吉亚的粉丝提问。你知道，我们浏览了不同的
styles of conflict resolution. And Aiden wanted to know, did it ever mention in the script what the number two and number three resolutions were in the five different styles of conflict? I don't know, but I know what the five are. The only one that's referred to in the script that isn't listed in this scene is compromise. So the five types of conflict resolution are lose, lose, win, lose, compromise, win, win, and win, win, win. So they're really, Michael's really keyed in on a win, win, win. Because then even he wins. Yes. We know lose loses number one. And then Angela just wants him to just skip to win, win. And he goes, that's number four. But then I love Steve's performance so much when
冲突解决风格。阿登想知道，剧本里有没有提到在五种不同的冲突风格中，第二和第三种解决方法是什么？我不知道，但我知道那五种是什么。剧本中提到的唯一没有在这个场景中列出的就是妥协。所以五种冲突解决类型是：双输、赢输、妥协、双赢，以及共赢。所以他们真的，迈克尔真的很看重共赢。因为那样连他自己也能赢。是的。我们知道双输是第一种。然后安吉拉只想让他直接跳到双赢。他说那是第四号。但后来我太喜欢史蒂夫的表现了，当
he starts to read number five. And here's the thing that Steve is doing. He's reading something and making it look like he's never read it before and that he's getting surprised as he reads it. Yes. Even though you and I both know he knew those lines backwards and forwards. So he's like, oh, number five, win, win, win. Oh, I win. I win too because I resolved it. And it's just, he's so good just in that very like small moment. You see how great he is at finessing all of these, these little moments.
他开始读第五号的时候。史蒂夫是这样做的。他在读一些东西，却表现得好像他从来没读过一样，而且在阅读时表现得很惊讶。是的。尽管你我都清楚，他对那些台词早已倒背如流。所以他就说：哦，第五号，共赢。哦，我赢了。我也赢了，因为我解决了问题。这真是……他在那个非常短暂的时刻表现得太棒了。你看他在处理所有这些小细节时有多么出色。
I love it. They should play that in acting schools as an example of moment of discovery. All right. So at four minutes, 32 seconds, they go over to quote, look at the disputed poster. Michael wants them to express their feelings. And I say that the poster makes me happy because it makes me feel like the, the babies are the real artists that God has a funny sense of humor. And Oscar at five minutes, two seconds just goes off and he has this rant. It was so fun to do this with Oscar. I have known him for so long. We performed together in sketch comedy. So I knew when they told him he could uncork what that meant. And it was just a, it was a delight for me when he was like, you know what? It's, it's
我太喜欢了。他们应该把这个当作发现时刻的例子在表演学校里播放。好吧。所以在4分32秒时，他们走过去，所谓的“查看有争议的海报”。迈克尔希望他们表达自己的感受。我说这张海报让我开心，因为它让我觉得，婴儿才是真正的艺术家，上帝有一种幽默感。而奥斯卡在5分02秒时突然爆发了，他发表了一大通言论。和奥斯卡一起演这场戏太有趣了。我认识他很久了。我们一起表演过素描喜剧。所以我知道当他们告诉他可以敞开宣泄时这意味着什么。当他说“你知道吗，这是
kitsch. It's the opposite of art. It destroys art. It destroys souls. It just goes off. Was that improvised or scripted, Angela, or a mixture? It was a mixture. It was a mixture. And I think that was mostly scripted, but his stuff with Paul, with Toby in the conference room at the top of that scene was improvised. But, but Oscar is just so funny in this. And I just remember it was hard to keep a straight face. I remember that. I had you to my right and Oscar to my left. It was very hard. It was very hard for me because Pam doesn't have any lines. And my direction was that I was not to react. I was to remain very neutral as possible. And so that was difficult to
庸俗艺术。这是艺术的反面。它摧毁艺术。它摧毁灵魂。”然后大发雷霆时，我感到非常开心。安吉拉，那是即兴发挥还是剧本写的，或者是两者的结合？那是结合。那是结合。我认为这大部分是剧本写的，但他和保罗（即托比）在场景开头的会议室里的对手戏是即兴发挥的。但是，但是奥斯卡在这一集里太搞笑了。我只记得很难忍住不笑。我记得。你挨着我的右边，奥斯卡在我的左边。太难了。对我来说太难了，因为帕姆没有台词。我的导演要求是我不能有任何反应。我要尽可能保持中立。所以这很难办到
be neutral. All right. Well, we had a fan question from Zoe Kennedy. What do you guys think a win, win, win solution to Oscar and Angela's dispute with the baby poster would be? Because, you know, Michael's win, win, win solution is that Oscar will turn the baby poster into a t-shirt t shirt he has to wear because then he won't see it. But Angela will see it all the time. Yes. And neither of them like no, they're like, neither of them like that. So what would you make it be? And what's your win, win, win? I would say that you could have personal items that could fit on your desk. And as long as they weren't offensive, they could stay on your desk. I like that. You shrink it down to like no bigger than
保持中立。好吧。嗯，我们收到了来自佐伊·肯尼迪的粉丝提问。你们觉得奥斯卡和安吉拉关于婴儿海报的纠纷，有什么双赢、双赢、再双赢的解决方法吗？因为，你知道的，迈克尔的双赢、双赢、再双赢的解决方案是让奥斯卡把婴儿海报做成一件他必须穿的T恤，因为这样他就看不到了。但安吉拉会一直看到它。是的。而且他们俩都不——不，他们就像，他们俩都不喜欢那样。那你们会怎么设计呢？你们的双赢、双赢、再双赢是什么？我会说你可以放一些能放在你桌子上的个人物品。只要它们不具攻击性，就可以放在你的桌子上。我喜欢这个。你把它缩小到大概不比
an eight by 10. And then she could put it on her desk. And that would be my win, win, win. Angela, that is a great solution. You, yeah, you set a new rule that personal items can be no larger than eight by 10. Just that's it. That's it, everyone. You heard it here. You heard it here. All right. So moving on, what is next? So Angela, we got a really cool fan question about this scene from Marisela Cabuto. And I loved it so much. I reached out and I asked her if she would send me a recording of her asking the question. So here it goes. When Michael is trying to solve the Angela Oscar dispute, they are all standing in the accounting area. On a column behind Michael, there is a certificate of participation
八乘十的尺寸。然后她就可以把它放在她的桌子上了。这就是我的双赢、双赢、再双赢。安吉拉，这真是个绝佳的解决方法。你，是的，你定了一条新规则，个人物品最大不能超过八乘十。就这样。就是这样，各位。你们在这里听到了。你们在这里听到了。好的，那么继续，接下来是什么？那么安吉拉，我们收到了一个来自玛丽塞拉·卡布托的关于这个场景的非常酷的粉丝提问。我太喜欢了。我联系了她，问她是否能发给我一段她提问的录音。所以，录音来咯。当迈克尔试图解决安吉拉和奥斯卡的纠纷时，他们都站在会计区。在迈克尔身后的一根柱子上，有一张
for a Mark Christie. Who is that? I was so excited to get this question, Angela. So this moment happens at four minutes, 32 seconds. And right next to Steve's head on this pillar, reception is behind the pillar, you can see this plaque. It's exactly what Marisela described. It is a certificate of participation for Mark Christie. This is one of my favorite things about our set. Okay. So Mark was the best boy grip and the key grip for seasons one through three on the office. And it's the art department that is ultimately responsible for any kind of card sign certificate or logo that's created specifically for the show. So our art department created the Dunder Mifflin logo and they created all of the little plaques and signs and certificates
给马克·克里斯蒂的参与证书。那是谁？我太高兴能收到这个问题了，安吉拉。所以这个时刻发生在四分三十二秒。在柱子上史蒂夫脑袋的旁边，接待处就在柱子后面，你可以看到这个牌匾。这正是玛丽塞拉所描述的。这是一张给马克·克里斯蒂的参与证书。这是我最喜欢我们片场的的事情之一。好吧。所以马克是《办公室》第一季到第三季的最佳大助手和灯光大助手。最终负责为节目专门创作的任何种类的卡片、标志、证书或标志的是美术部门。所以我们的美术部门创作了邓德米夫林的标志，他们创作了所有的小牌匾、标志和证书
that hang around the office. And in an effort to give just like a fun personal touch, they would include the names of real crew members. Yes. So for example, we also had a salesman of the year and a humanitarian of the year plaque. And those plaques featured our crew member names as well. But really, you can see them everywhere. You'll start to notice them as you watch episodes. I do now. I look for them. There are tons that are just sprinkled throughout the whole office. Well, let me tell you what my favorite one is. Okay. Okay. So my favorite one involves our first AD Kelly Cantley. You guys might remember her Kelly. Her job is keeping all of the actors on schedule. She makes sure that we arrive for our scenes
挂在办公室周围。为了营造一种有趣而个人化的氛围，他们会把真实剧组成员的名字放进去。是的。所以例如，我们还有一个年度最佳推销员和一个年度人道主义者牌匾。这些牌匾上也印了我们剧组成员的名字。但实际上，你到处都能看到它们。当你观看剧集时，你会开始注意到它们。我现在会了。我四处找它们。有成吨的牌匾点缀在整个办公室里。好吧，让我告诉你我最喜欢的是哪一个。好的。好的。所以我最喜欢的一个涉及我们的第一副导演凯莉·坎特利。你们可能还记得她，凯莉。她的工作是让所有演员按日程进行。她确保我们到达我们的场景
when we're supposed to. And she is also the one who would run our safety meetings. Yes. So Kelly Cantley was safety meeting lit candle on set. That's Kelly Cantley. We have a pair of scissors in someone's hand safety meeting. Exactly. Exactly. But Kelly really had to keep the whole production on time. Everything happening on the set. All of us working together and and getting our day done making our day. She's by far one of the most important elements to running the show for sure. Well, I guess that Kelly had gone around and looked at all the plaques and she noticed that her name was not on any of them. I could kind of picture Kelly doing that, actually. She spent a couple of days sort of doing this bit where she was
在应该到的时间。她也是负责召开安全会议的人。是的。所以凯莉·坎特利就是片场安全会议点燃蜡烛的人。那是凯莉·坎特利。我们手里拿着一把剪刀在进行安全会议。没错。没错。但凯莉确实必须让整个制作按时进行。片场发生的一切。我们所有人都一起工作，完成当天的拍摄，搞定一天的工作。毫无疑问，她绝对是维持节目运转的最重要因素之一。好吧，我猜凯莉曾经四处查看所有的牌匾，她注意到她的名字不在任何一个上面。其实我能想象出凯莉那样做的样子。她花了好几天时间做了一出戏，当时她
all like, oh, I see. No, no, Kelly Cantley. There's my name is on it. It was very funny. And then all of a sudden, one day, a new plaque showed up. It's on the pole over by Stanley's desk. And here's what it said. It said, whereas it came to our attention that Kelly Cantley was whining that a lowly second assistant director had a plaque with her name on it. And whereas Kelly Cantley made a comment on the air regarding that fact, we have decided to give her this certificate because we love her. And so and then they just waited for her to notice it. And then it stayed there for the rest of the run of the show. So guys, something fun to do, you can go through, try to hit pause whenever you see these certificates. And you can see
就像，哦，我明白了。不，不，凯莉·坎特利。上面有我的名字。非常搞笑。然后突然有一天，一块新牌匾出现了。它在斯坦利办公桌旁边的柱子上。上面是这样写的：鉴于我们注意到凯莉·坎特利一直在抱怨一个卑微的第二助理导演居然有一个印有她名字的牌匾。鉴于凯莉·坎特利在节目中对这一事实发表了评论，我们决定把这个证书授予她，因为我们爱她。所以然后他们就等着她注意到它。然后它就一直挂在那里，直到这部剧结束。所以伙计们，一个有趣的事情是，你可以通读一遍，每当你看到这些证书时试着按暂停。你可以看到
some names of our crew members. I think it's just a really, really great way to honor them. And this is actually a very popular thing that happens on sets. Yes. All right, I love that question. I love hearing the behind the scenes of our crew. But Jenna, it's time to get into the save the date. Yes. Six minutes, 28 seconds. We get a real bird's eye view of this. Well, Pam has broken down and is giving Angela a save the date hand delivered. We have a fan question from Ms. Lavender Darling. She said, Pam's save the date invitations say place TBA. Why did she bother making a save the date with a location TB? TBD. When I looked at the save the date, okay, first of all, Angela's throwing shade. She's
我们剧组成员的一些名字。我觉得这真的是一种非常非常好的致敬方式。这实际上是片场非常流行的一件事。是的。好的，我很喜欢那个问题。我喜欢听我们剧组的幕后故事。但是珍娜，是时候进入“敲定日期”了。是的。六分钟二十八秒。我们对这个场景有了一个真正的鸟瞰视角。好吧，帕姆终于崩溃了，亲手把“敲定日期”邀请函交给了安吉拉。我们有一个来自拉文德·达林女士的粉丝提问。她说，帕姆的“敲定日期”邀请函上写着地点待定。为什么她要费心思制作一个地点待定的“敲定日期”？待定。当我看到这个“敲定日期”时，好吧，首先，安吉拉在暗讽。她
like it's hand delivered, but it's okay. But it's also not my taste. So she's throwing a lot of shade. But I screen grabbed the save the date and it says save the date and then written in hand. So, you know, it's printed, but then you've got to fill in everything by hand. It says for the wedding, Pam Beasley to Roy Anderson date, June 10th place to be determined. The save the date gives us nothing. Everyone in the office knew it was going to be June 10th because Roy announced it drunkenly on booze cruise. We know it's between the two of you. The save the date is pointless. Yeah. It's a waste of time. It's a waste of money. Kind of like their wedding. Oh, no. Can I get an Angela sass, please? I did. I did. I did. Sam. Angela sass. There it is.
就像是它是亲手送的，但这没关系。但这也合我的胃口。所以她有很多暗讽。但我截取了“敲定日期”的屏幕画面，上面写着“敲定日期”，然后是手写的。所以，你知道，它是印刷的，但你必须手写填完所有内容。上面写着为了这场婚礼，帕姆·比斯利嫁给罗伊·安德森，日期是6月10日，地点待定。这个“敲定日期”什么都没告诉我们。办公室里的每个人都知道会是6月10日，因为罗伊在“酒水巡航”上喝醉后宣布了。我们知道这在你们俩之间。这个“敲定日期”毫无意义。是的。这是在浪费时间。这是在浪费金钱。有点像他们的婚礼。哦，不。我能得到一句安吉拉式的刻薄话吗，拜托？我有。我有。我有。
I agree with you, Angela. I think that these rather lame handwritten save the dates are a waste of time. Did you do save the dates for your wedding or did you just send an invitation? Well, you know, I did just an email save the date. Yeah. I did an email. Yeah. That's a little bit where we are now. I think I'll say I did a save the date, a hard copy save the date thing, I think. Why? It's a waste of time. I don't know. It's a waste of time. It's because it was like etiquette back then. Way back then. No, but it's true. I think there's a lot that has changed. I remember getting in a huge argument with my mom about wedding planning because in her generation, the bride planned the wedding with her parents because her parents paid for the wedding and it
我同意你的看法，安吉拉。我觉得这些相当蹩脚的手写“敲定日期”是在浪费时间。你为你的婚礼做过“敲定日期”，还是只发了请柬？好吧，你知道，我只发了一封电子邮件的“敲定日期”。是的。我发了一封电子邮件。是的。这就是我们现在的现状。我想我会说我做过“敲定日期”，纸质版的“敲定日期”那种，我想。为什么？这是在浪费时间。我不知道。这是在浪费时间。因为这就像是当时的礼节。很久很久以前。不，但这是真的。我觉得有很多事情都变了。我记得为了婚礼筹备跟我妈妈大吵了一架，因为在她那个时代，新娘和父母一起筹备婚礼，因为她父母出钱办婚礼，那
was like a party they threw for the bride and groom. And I said, I want to plan my wedding with my husband, the person who's going to be my husband. Like my mom wanted to pick out our registry items with me and I was like, that feels so weird to me that I would go with my mom to pick out my dishes. Wouldn't I go with the person who's going to eat off the plates with me to pick them out? But there was like a generational divide in like how these things are done. And I feel like this is going to point to like another generational divide. Like remember when you used to send these papers save the date or even these paper wedding invitations. Nowadays, I get invited to weddings all the time where it's all online. I get an email and then I click on this website and the registry
就像他们为新娘和新郎举办的一场派对。而我说，我想和我的丈夫，那个将要成为我丈夫的人一起筹备我的婚礼。就像我妈妈想和我一起挑选我们的结婚登记礼物，而我觉得和妈妈一起去挑餐具感觉太奇怪了。难道我不应该和那个将要和我一起用这些盘子吃饭的人一起去挑吗？但这其中存在一种代际分水岭，关于这些事情是如何处理的。我觉得这会指向另一个代际分水岭。就像还记得你以前发送这些纸质“敲定日期”甚至这些纸质婚礼请柬的时候吗。现在，我经常收到参加婚礼的邀请，全都是网上的。我收到一电子邮件，然后我点击这个网站，登记
links are there and the RSVP is there and it's like all there and it's actually kind of awesome. I like a lot of it that's online now. It makes it very easy to find information but I still like getting a hand proper invitation. I don't need to save the date. I don't need a little card with directions. I don't need a little special card that lets you know if I want to eat chicken or the pasta. But I like getting the paper invitation. For some of my dearest friends, I've saved them. I don't know. I also am a little bit of a packrat as we know. I scrapbook. So I like getting the actual paper invitation myself. I can be with you on that. I really like getting a paper thank you. Yeah. Like a thank you card in the mail. That's nice. As opposed to
链接在那里，回复邀请也在那里，而且就像全都在那儿，实际上真的很棒。我挺喜欢现在网上这些东西的。它使查找信息变得非常容易，但我仍然喜欢收到一份得体的纸质请柬。我不需要“敲定日期”。我不需要一张带路线的小卡片。我不需要一张特别的小卡片来让你知道我想吃鸡肉还是意大利面。但我喜欢收到纸质请柬。对于我的一些挚友，我都把它们保存了下来。我不知道。正如我们所知，我也是个有点爱囤积东西的人。我做手账。所以我自己挺喜欢收到真正的纸质请柬的。我赞同你这一点。我真的很喜欢收到纸质的感谢信。是的。比如一封寄到邮箱里的感谢信。那很好。而不是像
you. For a big event like a wedding, I don't need a paper thank you if I gave you a birthday present or something. But if it's a big event like a wedding, I think the process of a couple sitting down and writing out their thank you cards is a really nice tradition and I think it is... What's the word I'm looking for? Proper? I feel like if you're giving like... Yeah. The significance of a wedding gift deserves the significance of a handwritten thank you card. I can go with that. I can go with that. Well, Angela, I have to say that for being an episode about conflict resolution, we just did not have a conflict about that. We were in total agreement. We talked that out and we agree. You also liked my resolution for the jazz poster. So
你那样。对于像婚礼这样的大型活动，如果我送了你生日礼物什么的，我不需要纸质感谢信。但如果这是一个像婚礼这样的大型活动，我认为一对新人坐下来写感谢信的过程是一个非常好的传统，而且我认为它是……我正在找的那个词是什么？得体？我觉得如果你送了……是的。一份婚礼礼物的分量值得一份手写感谢信的分量。我赞成这个。我赞成这个。好吧，安吉拉，我必须说，作为一个关于冲突解决的剧集，我们对这一点根本没有发生冲突。我们完全达成了一致。我们谈妥了，并且我们意见一致。你也喜欢我对爵士乐海报的解决方案，所以
we're finding some common ground here. Yeah. We're really resolving things. So there you go. We're on brand. All right. Let's take a break. I'm going to get a snack. All right. We're going to take a break and we will be back. Okay. We are back from break. We have discussed Pam's very lame save the date. Yeah. And now Michael fresh off his, I guess, his win-win-win with Oscar and Angela decides he's going to demand from Toby that he be given all of the unresolved complaints. All of them. And he takes them from Toby forcibly. He says, quote, I had to use win-lose on that. It was not pretty. Yeah. But now he's got them and he is going to start resolving conflicts. He's just going to stir the pot. That's what he's going to do. At seven minutes
我们在这里找到了共同点。是的。我们真的在解决问题。所以你看。我们符合品牌形象。好的。我们休息一下。我要去吃点零食。好的。我们要休息一下，一会儿就回来。好的。我们休息回来了。我们讨论了帕姆那份非常蹩脚的“敲定日期”。是的。现在迈克尔刚解决了，我猜，他与奥斯卡和安吉拉的双赢，他决定要求托比把所有未解决的投诉都交给他。所有的。他从托比手里强行拿走了它们。他说，原话是：“我不得不在这上面使用双赢/输。这过程可不好看。”是的。但现在他拿到了，他要开始解决冲突了。他只是要去挑拨离间。这就是他要做的事。在七分钟
and 40 seconds, Pam is in the conference room with Michael and they're going through all the complaints. And I have to say, Ange, in this scene, I really liked the callback for Stanley with Miracle Whip. Did you hear that one? Yes. The complaint that is from Kevin that Stanley keeps using his Miracle Whip without asking, which is a callback from when Jim was doing that Stanley impression during drug testing. And his bit was, I like the tangy zip of Miracle Whip. Yeah. Yeah. I love that. So also, there's something else that I think was pretty fantastic. If you love a really good eye roll, you need to go to eight minutes, 35 seconds. Angela, I wrote it down too. There is a Pam eye roll to end all eye rolls. It is substantial. It is. Well, Michael has gone into
四十秒，帕姆和迈克尔在会议室里，他们正在过目所有的投诉。我必须说，安姬，在这个场景中，我真的很喜欢斯坦利关于奇妙酱的那个梗。你听到了吗？听到了。凯文的投诉是斯坦利未经允许一直在用他的奇妙酱，这是对吉姆在药物检测期间模仿斯坦利的一个呼应。他的台词是：“我喜欢奇妙酱那种带劲的酸味。”是的。是的。我太喜欢了。所以，还有一件事我认为相当棒。如果你喜欢一个非常棒的翻白眼，你需要跳到八分钟三十五秒。安吉拉，我也记下来了。这里有一个堪称翻白眼之最的帕姆式翻白眼。它非常彻底。确实如此。好吧，迈克尔走进了
the bullpen to ask people if they feel like Toby really solved their complaints or if they were merely listened to and forgot about. And he starts reading all the complaints out loud. And that's when I wrote down major Pam eye roll sass. Some major Pam sass right there. And so then there's this thing I remember laughing. I remember like breaking in this at eight minutes, 53 seconds. Michael says, oh, and there's a Phyllis Angela dispute. And I say, you already did me. And he goes, oh, that's what she said. And Jim mouths it as Michael says it. Yeah. That was scripted. That was not John improvising. That was a scripted moment. And the camera sort of pretends like it's going to find John doing that. It's really great. I think that's a great example of the choreography
开放式办公区，询问大家是否觉得托比真的解决了他们的投诉，还是只是听取了然后就抛诸脑后了。他开始大声朗读所有的投诉。也就是在那时我记下了：帕姆式的重大翻白眼和刻薄。那里有一些帕姆式的重大刻薄。然后有这么一件事我记得我笑了。我记得在八分钟五十三秒时我笑喷了。迈克尔说，“哦，还有一个菲利斯和安吉拉的纠纷。”我说，“你已经对我做过了。”然后他说，“哦，她就是这么说的。”当迈克尔说这句话时，吉姆用嘴型默默说出来。是的。那是剧本里写好的。那不是约翰即兴发挥的。那是剧本里写好的时刻。镜头假装好像要捕捉到约翰做这个动作。真的太棒了。我觉得这是一个很好的摄影机调度例子
with the camera. The discovery moment. Yeah, exactly. We also find out some interesting information about Dwight and Angela, which is we now have a timestamp because for six months, Angela has been complaining about Dwight and that that was all redacted for the last six months. Yes. All of Angela's complaints about Dwight were redacted six months ago. Six months. I'd love to read what some of those complaints were. Well, we know one of them. One of them has to do with safety officer. I'm sure she filed a complaint about that. I'm sure all of her complaints are just based on who is really in charge of this or that. But now Michael just starts listing things off and he's one by one getting everyone pissed off at each other. Everyone is getting angry with each other.
带有发现的时刻。是的，完全正确。我们还发现了一些关于德怀特和安吉拉的有趣信息，那就是我们现在有了一个时间戳，因为在过去的六个月里，安吉拉一直在抱怨德怀特，而这在过去六个月里全都被删节了。是的。安吉拉对德怀特的所有投诉在六个月前都被删节了。六个月。我很想读读其中一些投诉是什么。好吧，我们知道其中一个。其中一个与安全官有关。我确信她为此提交了一份投诉。我确信她所有的投诉都只是基于谁才是这里真正的主管。但现在迈克尔只是开始列举事情，他一个接一个地让每个人都对彼此火大。每个人都开始对彼此生气。
Pam first volunteers to save Angela because it seems like it's going to be revealed to the office if anyone thinks real hard on this that, hmm, why did Angela redact all of her complaints? Only Dwight. Yeah, against only Dwight. So, Pam volunteers, but there's only one complaint against Pam and it's been withdrawn and this was the complaint. Does she have to plan her wedding on office time? Can't she do that from home? And Pam assumes that it was Angela who complained about her. Pam totally glares at Angela and Angela's like, what? What? Like, and I believe her. I believe her. Well, yeah, she didn't complain about her. No. Yeah. But I think it's reasonable for Pam to assume that she did. Well, true because Angela, I think, has the most complaints of anyone else.
帕姆首先主动提出拯救安吉拉，因为如果有人在这上面仔细想想，似乎办公室里就会真相大白，嗯，为什么安吉拉删除了她所有的投诉？只有对德怀特的投诉。是的，只针对德怀特。所以，帕姆主动请缨，但针对帕姆的投诉只有一个，而且已经被撤回了，投诉内容是这样的。她必须在办公室时间筹划婚礼吗？她不能从家里做吗？帕姆猜测是安吉拉投诉了她。帕姆狠狠地瞪着安吉拉，而安吉拉则是一副“什么？什么？”的表情。就像，而且我相信她。我相信她。好吧，是的，她没有投诉她。没有。是的。但我认为帕姆猜测是她投诉的也是合理的。好吧，确实如此，因为安吉拉，我觉得，比其他任何人的投诉都多。
Yes. In the complaint box. This is true. But you're right. Then Michael goes around and just starts throwing out all of everybody's complaints. We have to point out that at 10 minutes 53 seconds, we have an Angela Pam partition scene. I love it. These were some of my favorites and we didn't get to do very many of them because we would laugh and we would ruin take after take. But here it is, you and I over the partition having a heated conversation. Yes, Pam goes right up to Angela and says, thanks for ratting me out. I know you're so ticked off. Oh, I'm mad. Fan question from Colleen Keenan and Brittany Magart. They both asked, was Pam calling Dwight Bobblehead Joe scripted? Because I say, you and Bobblehead Joe. I know. They want to know if that was scripted. It was
是的。在投诉箱里。这是真的。但你是对的。然后迈克尔四处走动，开始抛出所有人的投诉。我们必须指出，在十分五十三秒，我们有一个安吉拉和帕姆隔板的场景。我太喜欢了。这些是我最喜欢的场景之一，而且我们没能拍很多，因为我们会笑场，然后毁掉一个又一个镜头。但就是这样，你和我隔着隔板进行激烈的对话。是的，帕姆径直走到安吉拉面前说：“谢谢你出卖我。”我知道你气炸了。哦，我很生气。来自科琳·凯南和布兰妮·玛加特的粉丝提问。他们两个都问，帕姆叫德怀特“摇头娃娃乔”是剧本里写好的吗？因为我说，“你和摇头娃娃乔。”我知道。他们想知道那是写好的吗。是
scripted. It was scripted. But guess what? Here's a little window into Pam. When she gets mad, she starts name calling. I guess so. Can I get a, Sam, could I get a little Pam sass here? Pam sass. Thank you. Yeah, that's appropriate. Pam sass. Because Pam keeps sassing. She sasses right into the kitchen and is complaining to Jim about Angela. And Jim's kind of like, oh, I don't know. He doesn't know. You know what? I wish, I wish we had a sting that said Jim Shade because he gives you some shade. He's like, oh, and what does Roy think about that? And she's like, well, I don't really talk to Roy about this. And he's like about your feelings and stuff. Yeah. Jim Shade. I like it. Well, now we move into the conference room. Angela, can you tell us about
写好的。那是写好的。但你猜怎么着？这里有一个了解帕姆的窗口。当她生气时，她开始骂人了。我想是的。萨姆，我能在这里得到一点帕姆式的刻薄吗？帕姆式的刻薄。谢谢。是的，那很合适。帕姆式的刻薄。因为帕姆一直在刻薄。她一路刻薄到厨房，向吉姆抱怨安吉拉。而吉姆有点像是，哦，我不知道。他不知道。你知道吗？我希望，我希望我们有一个音效叫“吉姆的暗讽”，因为他给了你一些暗讽。他就像是，“哦，罗伊怎么看那件事？”她就像是，“嗯，我其实不跟罗伊谈这个。”然后他就像是“关于你的感受什么的。”是的。吉姆的暗讽。我喜欢。好吧，现在我们进入会议室。安吉拉，你能给我们讲讲
this scene with you and Phyllis with Michael? This scene was really hard because Phyllis and I got tickled. We got tickled. But yeah. So, you know, here Angela and Phyllis are at it again. Now, in the bullpen, when Michael calls out Phyllis for having a complaint on Angela, she's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Angela and I are friends. But then Phyllis just starts turning on everyone. There's a deleted scene. That's also pretty great. So yeah. So Phyllis, clearly, I guess, has been parking in the parking spot where Angela likes to park even though they're not named parking spots. We don't have individual spots. But clearly, my character likes to park in the same spot every day. And Phyllis has been parking in it. And I'm ticked off. So I complained.
你和菲利斯跟迈克尔一起的这个场景吗？这个场景真的很难，因为菲利斯和我都笑翻了。我们笑翻了。但话说回来。所以，你知道，这里安吉拉和菲利斯又杠上了。现在，在开放式办公区，当迈克尔指出菲利斯对安吉拉有意见时，她说，“我不知道你在说什么。安吉拉和我 是朋友。”但随后菲利斯开始针对所有人。有一个被删减的场景。那也很棒。所以，是的。所以菲利斯，很显然，我猜，一直停在安吉拉喜欢停车的那个车位上，尽管它们不是指定车位。我们没有个人的车位。但很显然，我的角色喜欢每天停在同一个车位上。而菲利斯一直停在那里。我气炸了。所以我投诉了。
And Phyllis is like, I'm sorry. I guess I forgot. I parked in the spot you liked even though we don't have a signed parking. But then at the very end, she goes, I don't like you. I know. Phyllis! Phyllis! Phyllis! And in the deleted scene, she tells Dwight she doesn't like him. I think that's some Phyllis sass. Phyllis sass. That one's hard. It's a lot of, it's like an S to an S. It's a lot of S's. This is when we're going to find out that Ryan thinks Creed has an old man smell. And Creed is like, oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I know what he's talking about. I grow mung beans in my desk. They're really nutritious, but they smell like death. I texted Creed last night about it. And I said, does he eat them in real life? I said, Creed, you're on my TV right now talking
而菲利斯就像是，“对不起。我想我忘了。我停在了你喜欢的车位上，尽管我们没有标明车位的牌子。”但最后她却说，“我讨厌你。”我知道。菲利斯！菲利斯！菲利斯！在被删减的场景中，她告诉德怀特她讨厌他。我觉得这可以说是菲利斯式的刻薄。菲利斯式的刻薄。那个很难。它有很多，就像S到S的发音。有很多S。这就是我们会发现瑞安觉得克里夫身上有股老人味的时候。而克里夫就像是，“哦，是的。哦，是的。我知道他在说什么。”我在我的办公桌里种绿豆。它们非常有营养，但它们闻起来像死亡。我昨晚还给克里夫发短信说这事。我说，他在现实生活中吃它们吗？我说，克里夫，你现在正在我的电视上谈论
about the mung beans in your drawer. And he said, I still talk to my mung beans. Oh, Creed. And he said, yeah. He said, I was eating mung beans exactly. That's exactly what it was. Wow. I said, how do they taste? And he said, they taste like grass and air mostly. Grass and air. Not really like death. Well, Angela, I looked up mung beans. And it turns out that they are really good for you, especially the sprouted ones. The sprouted ones have fewer calories and more amino acids and antioxidants than unsprouted ones. Let me tell you some benefits to eating mung beans, because I know you're curious. I can't wait. So they've done some studies in animals that have shown that
你抽屉里的绿豆。他说，我还在跟我的绿豆说话。哦，克里夫。他说，是的。他说，我当时正吃着绿豆，真的。情况就是这样。哇。我说，它们尝起来怎么样？他说，它们尝起来主要像草和空气。草和空气。其实不像死亡。好吧，安吉拉，我查了绿豆。结果发现它们对你真的很好，尤其是发过芽的。发过芽的绿豆比没发芽的卡路里更少，氨基酸和抗氧化剂更多。让我告诉你吃绿豆的一些好处，因为我知道你很好奇。我迫不及待了。所以他们做了一些动物实验，表明
mung beans help to reduce cholesterol. Okay. We're not doctors. I'm just a woman on the internet. So anything I say here right now. She's just a woman talking to you from her closet. Well, disclaimer. But they also seem to be a good source of potassium, magnesium, protein, and fiber. But here's the catch. If you are sprouting mung beans properly and you let them drain and then you rinse them off after you've let them soak, they won't smell. Only neglected mung beans stink. So Creed had some neglected mung beans in his desk. And that's why they smelled so badly. So anyway, I guess I just want people to know that if you've ever been curious about sprouting and eating some mung beans, they won't be stinky if you just care for them properly.
绿豆有助于降低胆固醇。好吧。我们不是医生。我只是一个上网的女人。所以我现在在这里说的一切。她只是一个在自己的衣帽间里跟你说话的女人。好吧，免责声明。但它们似乎也是钾、镁、蛋白质和纤维的良好来源。但问题来了。如果你把绿豆发芽处理得当，让它们沥干水分，在浸泡后把它们冲洗干净，它们就不会有味道。只有疏于照料的绿豆才会发臭。所以克里夫在他的办公桌里有一些疏于照料的绿豆。这就是它们为什么味道那么难闻的原因。总之，我猜我只是想让人们知道，如果你曾经对发豆芽和吃绿豆感到好奇，只要你好好照料它们，它们就不会有臭味。
According to the internet, I'm not an expert. And according to Creed, they taste like grass and air. So there you go. All right. Kevin has been making sexually suggestive comments to Angela that make her uncomfortable. So Michael suggests that the solution is for Angela to make sexual comments about Kevin that will make him uncomfortable. First of all, Kevin Gross, once again, we have been tracking Kevin's purveness. Is that a sting? Kevin Perve. Our whole podcast is just going to be stings. It's going to be like Angela Sass, Kevin Perve. Pam Shade. Okay. Now we're back in the break room. We're back to making our IDs and our badges, right? And at 13 minutes, 11 seconds, my stepson, Jack, it's one of his favorite talking heads where Dwight said he would never
根据互联网所说，我不是专家。而根据克里夫所说，它们尝起来像草和空气。所以就这样吧。好吧，凯文一直在对安吉拉说一些带性暗示的言论，这让她很不舒服。所以迈克尔建议解决的办法是让安吉拉对凯文说一些会让他感到不舒服的性暗示言论。首先，凯文太恶心了，我们再次一直在追踪凯文的色鬼行径。那是一个音效吗？凯文色鬼。我们的整个播客最后全都是音效了。会像是安吉拉的刻薄，凯文色鬼。吉姆的暗讽。好吧。现在我们回到了休息室。我们回到了制作工牌和胸卡的地方，对吧？在十三分钟十一秒，我的继子杰克，这是他最喜欢的talking heads之一，德怀特说他绝不会
smile in a photo because yeah, that's a sign of weakness. And so he's never going to smile in a photo, which just cracked us up. Jim is making this oversized ID badge for Dwight. He's playing a prank on him, you guys. This is classic Jim, right? And he put Dwight's middle name as fart. Yep. And he says he's a security threat. Well, we had a fan catch by Molly Torres. She says, at 14 minutes, 42 seconds, there is a close up shot of the prank ID badge that Jim made for Dwight. And his title is assistant to the regional manager. But he had been promoted to assistant regional manager in season two, episode six. This is another layer to Jim's prank. Yes. So it goes unmentioned in the episode. But yes, another layer to the prank badge is that he gives him his
在照片里笑，因为是的，那是软弱的标志。所以他绝不会在照片里笑，这简直让我们笑翻了。吉姆正在为德怀特制作这个超大的胸卡。他在捉弄他，伙计们。这是典型的吉姆，对吧？他把德怀特的中间名写成了“屁”。没错。他说他是一个安全威胁。好吧，我们有一个由莫莉·托雷斯发现的粉丝彩蛋。她说，在十四分钟四十二秒，有一个吉姆为德怀特制作的整蛊胸卡的特写镜头。他的头衔是地区经理助理。但他在第二季第六集就被升为助理地区经理了。这是吉姆恶作剧的又一个层面的阴谋。是的。所以这在剧集中没有被提及。但是的，恶作剧胸卡的另一个层面是，他给了他那个他最喜欢的不恰当头衔。
improper title that he loves to do. Yes, that's right. Well, it's at this point that Dwight storms over to Toby. He's had enough. And he finds out that Toby has just been putting his complaints about Jim in a box. He has not been registering them with corporate the way he said. Now Dwight is furious and he goes marching in to find Michael. And he says a line that I love. Four years of malfeasances. Yes. Yes. And he says, I cannot work with Jim anymore. One of them has to go. Michael has to pick by the end of the day. Yeah. He is officially furious. And you know what? This is all coming back to bite Michael in the butt because Toby said, just let him vent. And then I file it and I never do anything about it. And they got to vent. And
是的，没错。好吧，正是在这个时候，德怀特气势汹汹地走向托比。他受够了。他发现托比只是把关于吉姆的投诉塞进了一个箱子里。他根本没有像他说的那样向总公司登记。现在德怀特怒火中烧，他气势汹汹地去找迈克尔。他说了一句我非常喜欢的台词。四年的玩忽职守。是的。是的。他说，我再也不能和吉姆一起工作了。必须走一个。迈克尔必须在今天结束前做出选择。是的。他正式被惹火了。你知道吗？这一切都回过头来狠狠地咬了迈克尔一口，因为托比曾说，就让他发泄吧。然后我把它归档，从来不管它。他们得到了发泄，
that's that. Yeah. And now it's all catching up with Michael. He realizes that Toby probably had the right idea. Yes. Well, Dwight goes online and starts looking up jobs at other branches. And Dunderpedia had a really great list of all the jobs that are available at 14 minutes, 56 seconds. If you pause on the screen, here are the jobs that are available within Dunder Mifflin. Are you ready? Mm hmm. At Stanford, there is a plant manager and a sales manager position. The sales manager position requires three to five years of experience and a bachelor's degree. And there is an IT manager position available at Stanford. Here's my question. Isn't Josh Porter the... Oh, is he the branch manager? He's the branch manager. Well, within our office, I guess
事情就这样了。是的。现在这一切都报应在迈克尔身上了。他意识到托比当时可能才是对的。是的。好吧，德怀特上网开始查看其他分公司的职位。邓德百科有一个非常棒的列表，列出了在十四分钟五十六秒时所有可用的职位。如果你在屏幕上按下暂停，以下是邓德米夫林内部可用的职位。准备好了吗？嗯哼。在斯坦福，有一个工厂经理和一个销售经理职位。销售经理职位要求三到五年经验和学士学位。斯坦福还有一个IT经理职位。我的问题是。难道乔许·波特不是……哦，他是分公司经理吗？他是分公司经理。好吧，在我们办公室里，我猜
Michael is the branch manager. Who's the sales manager of Scranton? Probably. I mean, I don't know. Like Stanley? I would think Stanley because he's a senior. Yeah. He's been there a while. Yeah. But that's a job we don't ever really talk about. We never discuss. Yeah. So I just thought that was interesting. Well, in New York, Dunder Mifflin, they've got a position for maintenance engineer. In Albany, they need a comptroller and two regional managers. And in Buffalo, you can't read what it is, but they need someone. And Scranton has two positions available. Well, here's the thing. For a company that's downsizing and on the verge of collapse, why are all of these job openings? Thank you. What's up? Thank you. That too.
迈克尔是分公司经理。谁是斯克兰顿的销售经理？可能吧。我是说，我不知道。就像斯坦利？我想是斯坦利，因为他是老资历。是的。他在那儿呆了一段时间。是的。但那是我们从来不怎么讨论的一个职位。我们从不讨论。是的。所以我只是觉得这很有趣。好吧，在纽约邓德米夫林，他们有一个维修工程师的职位。在奥尔巴尼，他们需要一个审计长和两个地区经理。在布法罗，你看不清那是什么，但他们需要一个人。斯克兰顿有两个空缺职位。好吧，问题是。对于一家正在精简人员、濒临倒闭的公司来说，为什么会有这么多的职位空缺？谢谢。怎么回事？谢谢。还有那个。
But listen to the jobs that are available in Scranton. Warehouse staff and warehouse manager. But isn't Daryl the warehouse manager? Is he looking to leave? What's happening there? What's the story? I don't know. I don't know because he is the manager. After this, Michael calls Dwight and Jim into the conference room and he goes through a list of Dwight's complaints. And this is my favorite part of the episode. It's so good. And one of them made me laugh so hard. All right. Here are the list of pranks that Jim has pulled on Dwight that Dwight has reported. Ready? Okay. Yes. Ready, Jenna, go. Number one. Number one, he replaced all of Dwight's pens and pencils with crayons. Number two, he had everyone call him Dwayne all day. Which, by the way, Jenna,
但听听斯克兰顿有哪些空缺职位。仓库员工和仓库经理。但达里尔不是仓库经理吗？他想离开吗？那里发生什么事了？怎么回事？我不知道。我不知道，因为他确实是经理。在此之后，迈克尔把德怀特和吉姆叫进会议室，他过了一遍德怀特的投诉清单。这是我这一集中最喜欢的部分。太棒了。其中一条把我笑惨了。好吧。以下是吉姆对德怀特实施的、德怀特已经举报过的恶作剧列表。准备好了吗？好的。是的。准备好了，珍娜，开始。第一。第一，他把德怀特所有的钢笔和铅笔换成了蜡笔。第二，他让所有人一整天都叫他杜恩。顺便说一句，珍娜，
by the way, guess who would sometimes call him Dwayne? Who? In a scene. Who? Oscar. He did? For real. For real. There were scenes where he'd be like, listen, Dwight. And he'd be like, Dwight, it's Dwight. And he'd be like, ah crap. That is so funny. Somehow it went into Oscar's brain in real life. Okay. Well, Jim also placed a bloody glove in Dwight's desk drawer and tried to convince him that he had committed murder. Yes. Number four, Jim told Dwight there was an abandoned infant in the women's room. He went in to save the child and saw Meredith on the can. Yes. This one is my favorite. Of all time. Of any prank ever written about on the office. It's just a sentence. We never see this play out, but my imagination of it is so rich. Dwight says he hit himself in the head
顺便说一句，你猜谁有时候会叫他杜恩？谁？在哪个场景里。谁？奥斯卡。他叫过？真的假的。真的。有些场景里他会说，听着，德怀特。然后他会说，德怀特，我是德怀特。然后他会说，啊，该死。太搞笑了。不知怎么的，这在现实生活中进入了奥斯卡的脑子里。好吧。好吧，吉姆还在德怀特的办公桌抽屉里放了一只带血的手套，并试图让他相信他犯了谋杀罪。是的。第四，吉姆告诉德怀特女厕所里有一个被遗弃的婴儿。他进去救那个婴儿，结果看到梅雷迪斯在马桶上。是的。这一条是我最喜欢的。历来最喜欢的。在《办公室》里写过的所有恶作剧里。这只是一句话。我们从未看到这个情节上演，但我对它的想象是如此丰富。德怀特说他用电话机砸了自己的头
with his phone. And Michael is like, what? How could that have been Jim's fault? And then Jim in his talking head. It cuts to Jim. Yeah. He and John's reaction, he laughs. He says that he put nickels in Dwight's headset over the course of a long time so that it got heavier and heavier. And then one day he took them all out so that when Dwight hit sort of the phone, it would be super light. That is brilliant. That is brilliant. Greg Daniels. Yeah. Clap. That is brilliant. And that's the greatest. That is Jim doing the slow play. That is, that's I think why I like it, is the patience required for that prank. All right. There's more. Go. The next one is that every time Dwight typed his name, it would just say diaper. Diapers. Yeah. And then the last one is
而迈克尔就像是，什么？这怎么会是吉姆的错呢？然后是吉姆的talking head。镜头切到吉姆。是的。他和约翰的反应，他笑了。他说他花了很长时间在德怀特的耳机里放硬币，所以它变得越来越重。然后有一天他把所有的硬币都拿出来了，这样当德怀特撞到那类电话时，它就会超级轻。这太绝了。这太绝了。格雷格·丹尼尔斯。是的。鼓掌。这太绝了。这是最棒的。这就是吉姆在下慢棋。那就是，我觉得这就是我喜欢它的原因，那个恶作剧所需的耐心。还有更多。开始。下一个是每次德怀特打他的名字，上面就只会显示“尿布”。尿布。是的。然后最后一个是
that by the end of the day Dwight complains that his desk was moved two feet closer to the copier. And Jim admits that, yes, every time Jim got up from his desk, he moved it a little closer to the copier. But then Jim was like, well, when you, when you put them all together like that, it doesn't sound really cool. Yeah. I was like, oh, that sounds like maybe my life is kind of sad. Yeah. Maybe I suck. That's what I spent my time doing at 16 minutes, 39 seconds. I have a card that it just says a montage of sass. Oh, it's your montage of sass. It's a montage of sass. We see Phyllis, she slams the fridge door on Angela, Pam is glaring, eating yogurt, angry eating yogurt. And then you have like Creed and he's looking crazy and he's holding a pencil like it's a knife.
到了一天结束时，德怀特抱怨他的办公桌被朝复印机挪了两英尺。而吉姆承认，是的，每次吉姆从办公桌旁站起来，他都会把它往复印机挪近一点。但后来吉姆又觉得，嗯，当你们，当你们把所有这些连在一起看时，听起来确实不太酷。是的。我当时想，哦，听起来也许我的人生有点悲惨。是的。也许我很逊。这就是我在十六分钟三十九秒花时间做的事。我有一张卡片，上面只写着一连串的刻薄。哦，那是你的刻薄蒙太奇。这是一个刻薄蒙太奇。我们看到菲利斯，她把冰箱门摔在安吉拉身上，帕姆在怒瞪，气愤地吃着酸奶。然后你还有像克里夫，他看起来很疯狂，手里拿着一支铅笔，把它当成刀。
And I mean, then it just goes all through Stanley and Kevin and Kelly and Toby. Everyone is ticked off. Yeah. Everyone's just mad. It's a mad montage. It's a sass montage, really. It's a montage of sass. It is. Well, at 18 minutes, we have a fan catch from George Felton. Okay. Dwight's ID badge has been redone. His middle name is correct. It says Kurt. But you know what? If you look closely, he's still listed as a security threat. He didn't get that removed. Good catch, George. I liked that. There is a deleted scene where Pam chose Jim, her ID badge, and her clearance level is red. Yeah. And Jim's like, what does that mean? And Dwight's like, I'm not going to tell you. Also, Pam doesn't seem to know what it means either, which I thought was very funny.
我的意思是，然后这涵盖了斯坦利、凯文、凯莉和托比。每个人都气炸了。是的。每个人都很生气。这是一个生气的蒙太奇。实际上是一个刻薄蒙太奇。它是一个刻薄蒙太奇。确实如此。好吧，在十八分钟，我们有一个来自乔治·费尔顿的粉丝彩蛋。好的。德怀特的工牌被重新制作了。他的中间名是对的。上面写着库尔特。但你知道吗？如果你仔细看，他仍然被列为安全威胁。他没有把那个取消掉。干得漂亮，乔治。我很喜欢那个。有一个被删减的场景，帕姆选择了吉姆，她的工牌和她的清仓级别是红色的。是的。吉姆就像，那是什么意思？德怀特就像，我才不告诉你呢。还有，帕姆似乎也不知道那是什么意思，我觉得这非常搞笑。
All right. So guys, it's the end of the day. And Michael thinks that the way he could really boost everyone's morale after this hard day of resolving conflicts is to get a group photo. He wants a group photo. Stanley's like, are you kidding me? Seriously? So he gets everybody to stand. But a lot's happening. Like no one's smiling. This is when Jim tells Pam that he's the one who made the complaint against her about the wedding thing. And he said he was just venting. Oh my God. So awkward. How awkward. He's having this conversation during a group photo of his co-workers and you're like sandwiched between Phyllis and Stanley and Phyllis is listening to everything. Her reactions are amazing. So good. She literally says, oh dear.
好吧，伙计们，一天结束了。迈克尔认为，在经历了这个艰难的冲突解决日之后，他真正能提振大家士气的方法就是拍一张集体照。他想要一张集体照。斯坦利就像，你在开玩笑吧？说真的？所以他让每个人都站好。但发生了很多事。就像没有人笑。这就是吉姆告诉帕姆他才是那个就婚礼的事情对她进行投诉的人的时候。他说他只是在发泄。天哪。太尴尬了。多么尴尬。他在同事们的集体照拍摄期间进行这样的谈话，而你就夹在菲利斯和斯坦利中间，菲利斯在听着一切。她的反应太惊艳了。太棒了。她字面意思地说，“哦，天哪。”
Yes. Yes. I have a fan catch, another fan catch from Carly Mitchell. You know how earlier you were mentioning how your stepson Jack loves that talking head where Dwight says he doesn't smile because it's a sign of weakness and primates? Yeah. Guess who's smiling in the group photo? Who? Dwight. Dwight? Yeah. Dwight, what are you doing? Fan catch by Carly Mitchell, 18 minutes 50 seconds. He's smiling. You know what? I feel like this is like layered like emotionally for Dwight because he would not smile on his own but he will smile for Michael and that is his weakness. Michael is his weakness. Oh yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch. Okay. For this group photo moment. You know, Michael says it's really hard to get a photo of 15 people. Yeah. He says that's really hard. Guess
是的。是的。我有一个粉丝彩蛋，来自卡莉·密歇尔的又一个粉丝彩蛋。你知道你之前怎么提到你的继子杰克多么喜欢那个talking head，就是德怀特说他不笑因为那是软弱的标志和灵长类动物？是的。你猜谁在集体照里笑了？谁？德怀特。德怀特？是的。德怀特，你在干什么？卡莉·密歇尔的粉丝彩蛋，十八分钟五十秒。他在笑。你知道吗？我觉得这对德怀特来说在情感上是有层次的，因为他自己不会笑，但他会为了迈克尔笑，那是他的软弱。迈克尔是他的软弱。哦，是的。好吧，我有一个珍娜彩蛋。好的。为了这个集体照时刻。你知道，迈克尔说给十五个人拍照真的很难。是的。他说那真的很难。你猜
what? There's only 14 people in the photo. Jenna catch. Jenna catch. There you go. I love it. I love it. Well, and it's true. He never does get a photo so he photo shops the group photo. He says it's amazing what you can do with Photoshop and that's how he gets his group photo. And as you guys know, because we've shared with you, Greg then gave that photo to us all as a gift and I have it. I will, I will put it, I will hold up the photo of it next to me and put it on the website. So then this episode ends. It's kind of sad. Pam is checking her voicemail and she gets this voicemail from Jim saying, you know what? I'm not going to be in until the afternoon tomorrow because I have a doctor's appointment in the city that then we see what he's really doing. He's meeting with
怎么着？照片里只有十四个人。珍娜彩蛋。珍娜彩蛋。就是这样。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。好吧，确实如此。他从来没有真正拍成照片，所以他用PhotoshopP合成了集体照。他说你用Photoshop能做到这一点真是太神奇了，这就是他得到集体照的方式。正如你们所知，因为我们跟你们分享过，格雷格后来把那张照片作为礼物送给了我们所有人，我有它。我会，我会把它拿出来，我会把这张照片举在我旁边，然后放到网站上。然后这一集就结束了。这有点令人难过。帕姆在查她的语音信箱，她收到了吉姆的语音留言，说，你知道吗？我明天下午才能来上班，因为我在城里有一个医生预约，然后我们看到他在真正做什么。他在总公司与
Jan at corporate. Yeah. And you know, he's probably going to apply for that job at the Stanford branch. He's, he can't take it anymore. He can't watch. I think he's, yeah. Yeah. He can't watch her plan her wedding anymore. It's getting to be too much and it's heartbreaking. Yeah. He's, he's going to move on. The very end of this episode is an amazing little tribute to Raiders of the Lost Ark. It is. Where we see Toby putting this box of complaints and a wall of complaints, like with the forklift and the whole thing, it's very Raiders of the Lost Ark. Yes. We had a fan ask, Cole Edwards wanted to know, at the end of the episode, when we see Toby put that box of complaints in the warehouse, was it an homage to the end of Indiana Jones? It was. Yes, it was.
简会面。是的。而且你知道的，他可能会去申请斯坦福分公司的那个职位。他，他再也忍受不了了。他不能看着。我觉得他是，是的。是的。他再也不能看着她筹备婚礼了。这变得太多了，令人心碎。是的。他，他要前进了。这一集的结尾是对《夺宝奇兵》的一个惊人的小致敬。确实如此。我们看到托比把这箱投诉信和一个投诉墙放进仓库里，用叉车以及整套动作，非常《夺宝奇兵》。是的。我们有一个粉丝提问，科尔·爱德华兹想知道，在剧集结尾，当我们看到托比把那一箱投诉信放进仓库时，这是对《夺宝奇兵》结局的致敬吗？是的，它是。
And you guys, just for fun, if you're out there and you're going to rewatch it, go to 11 minutes, 43 seconds. Toby's company ID photo is my favorite. What is it? He sits down and he just says, just take the picture and he gets up and walks away. He takes it right as he walks away. Yes. Yes. It's pretty amazing. Angela, before we wrap up, we had a fan question from Devon Couch. Was there ever a baby poster shirt and did Oscar ever wear it? I went through all the deleted scenes and didn't see one, but do you know? No, I don't believe there was. I don't believe it, and I would have loved it. That would have been a fantastic callback years later if we had just seen him in that shirt one time or maybe like when Angela had to move in with Oscar, maybe she found
伙计们，就为了好玩，如果你正在看并且准备重温，去到十一分钟四十三秒。托比的公司工牌照片是我最喜欢的。是什么？他坐下来，然后说，直接拍照片吧，然后他就站起来走开了。他就在他走开的那一刻拍下了。是的。是的。这太棒了。安吉拉，在我们结束之前，我们收到了来自德文·考奇的粉丝提问。曾经有婴儿海报T恤吗？奥斯卡穿过吗？我翻遍了所有的被删减场景，没有看到，但你知道吗？不，我不认为有。我不相信有，我本来会很喜欢那个的。几年后如果我们只是看到他穿过一次那件T恤，或者当安吉拉不得不搬去和奥斯卡一起住时，也许她找到了
the shirt in his closet, something. But no, I don't have a memory of that, but that would have been fantastic. I agree. I wish that we owned the rights to that picture because I would buy that shirt. Would you buy it and wear it? Maybe. Why not? Why not? Why not? It's such like a, it would be such a fun inside joke, I think. You are wearing a hoodie right now with your own image on it, so. Office ladies? You know it. I always wear my office ladies hoodie when we record office ladies. It's like a uniform. It's my little uniform. I like a uniform. I went to a Catholic Girls High School. Yes, you know. I am kidding. Of course, you like the structure, you like uniform, you like order. How about that? Yes. You like order. Love order. Yeah. Feel very safe in order.
他衣橱里的T恤什么的，那将是一个非常棒的呼应。但没有，我对那个没有记忆，但那会太棒了。我同意。我希望我们拥有那张照片的版权，因为我会买那件T恤。你会买并穿上它吗？也许吧。为什么不呢？为什么不呢？为什么不呢？这真是一个，我觉得这将是一个非常有趣的内部笑话。你现在穿着一件印有你自己形象的连帽衫，所以。办公室女士们？你知道的。我们录制《办公室女士们》时我总是穿着我的办公室女士们连帽衫。这就像一套制服。这是我的小制服。我喜欢制服。我上的是天主教女子高中。是的，你懂的。我开玩笑呢。当然，你喜欢结构，你喜欢制服，你喜欢秩序。是不是这样？是的。你喜欢秩序。热爱秩序。是的。在秩序中感到非常安全。
There you go. Chaos. Terrifying to me. Terrifying. All right, you guys, this has been Conflict Resolution. We hope you enjoyed it. Thanks for listening in to us in our closets. We hope you're staying safe and, you know, we're sending you our love. We're sending you our love. Thanks, guys. Next week, we are going to be back with, oh, Ange. Oh, lady. Casino night. Lady, lady, lady. And a special guest. So tune in for that. Okay. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe.
就是这样。混乱。对我来说太可怕了。太可怕了。好吧，伙计们，这就是《冲突解决》。希望你们喜欢。谢谢你们收听我们在衣帽间里的节目。希望你们注意安全，而且，你知道的，我们向你们发送我们的爱。我们向你们发送我们的爱。谢谢大家。下周我们将带着，哦，安姬。哦，女士。赌场之夜。女士，女士，女士。还有一位特别嘉宾。所以请收听那一集。好的。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士们》。《办公室女士们》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里夫·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版的《办公室女士们》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。